En poco más de 10 días la república de
Afganistán se vino abajo y los talibanes
se hicieron con el poder. En todo el país
solo una provincia, la provincia de Panjshir,
hoy foco de una incipiente resistencia, logró
evitar la avalancha.
El avance talibán fue tan rápido que tal
y como todos pudisteis ver en vivo y en directo,
llegaron a poner contra la espada y la pared
a las mismísimas fuerzas norteamericanas
que tenían la misión de comandar la evacuación.
El caos por momentos fue total.
Tras 20 años, miles y miles de vidas perdidas
y un coste de más de 2,2 billones de dólares
según cálculos de la Universidad de Brown,
las dramáticas imágenes de la retirada norteamericana
de Saigón se volvían a repetir, aunque en
esta ocasión en un grado mucho mayor.
¿Cómo pudo ocurrir? ¿Cómo pudieron los
talibanes hacerse con el poder tan rápido?
(“Las tropas americanas no pueden ni deberían
luchar en una guerra y morir en una guerra
por la que las propias fuerzas afganas no
están dispuestas a luchar” Joe Biden, POTUS
El Presidente Biden mintió y debe avergonzarse.
Hemos perdido 70.000 hombres en la guerra.
Hemos llevado a cabo el 95% de todas las operaciones
desde 2014. Justo cuando estábamos despejando
Farah, el soporte aéreo, los suministros
y nuestras comunicaciones fueron suspendidos.
- Sarfaraz, Comando Afgano)
(“Nos ataron las manos a la espalda y vendieron
la patria, maldito el rico y su pandilla.
[..] Liberaremos Afganistán de estos terroristas.
¡La historia juzgará a Ghani, el amante
de su banda! General Bismillah Mohammadi,
Ministro de Defensa de la República Islámica
de Afganistán)
Se suponía que las fuerzas de seguridad afganas
estaban preparadas. Tras 20 años de entrenamiento
y preparación por parte de las tropas internacionales;
tras un gasto de Estados Unidos de más de
80.000 millones de dólares y con supuestamente
350.000 unidades entre el ejército y la policía
militarizada, la República de Afganistán
tenía que resistir.
Eso al menos fue lo que nos vendieron.
(23 de julio de 2018: "Estamos en el camino
correcto [...] El ejército y la policía
afganos están demostrando su voluntad de
tener éxito" John W. Nicholson Jr, General
de 4 estrellas y comandante en jefe de las
fuerzas estadounidenses en Afganistán entre
2016 y 2018)
Hemos provisto a nuestros socios afganos de
todas las herramientas, permitidme enfatizar:
de todas las herramientas, entrenamientos,
y equipamiento de cualquier ejército moderno.
Hemos provisto de armamento avanzado. Joe
Biden)
Pero, ¿Qué ocurrió para que un ejército
que desde el año 2014 se ha responsabilizado
de más del 95% de las operaciones militares
de repente se diluyera como un simple azucarillo?
¿Qué pasó en Afganistán para que los talibanes
se hicieran de nuevo con el poder sin apenas
resistencia?
Queridos amigos y amigas, ¿Por qué demonios
cayó Afganistán? En VisualPolitik hemos
preparado una trilogía de vídeos para tratar
de entender toda esta historia: pasado, presente
y futuro de la guerra más larga de los Estados
Unidos. De la última derrota militar de la
gran potencia norteamericana.
Nunca se pierde una guerra de forma alegre,
pero nadie imaginaba ver las estampas de derrota,
huída y descontrol que todos hemos presenciado.
Unas imágenes que acompañarán para siempre
como una pesada carga de negligencia, derrota
y mal hacer a la Administración de Joe Biden.
No había nada que yo ni nadie más viera
que indicara el colapso de este gobierno en
11 días - General Mark Milley, Presidente
del Estado Mayor Conjunto de los Estados Unidos)
Amigos, amigas, en este primer vídeo nos
vamos a centrar las 4 claves, las 4 hipótesis,que
explican la arrolladora victoría talibán.
Son 4 escenarios que se han producido y que
son complementarios entre sí. Lo que no sabemos
con certeza es el peso exacto que ha tenido
cada uno de ellos en la debacle afgana. Pero
sabemos que todos ellos han contribuido decisivamente
a lo ocurrido.
(Hemos sido traicionados. Nos dijeron que
un acuerdo de paz había sido alcanzado. Que
se estaba formando un gobierno de transición.
Que parásemos de luchar. Que volviéramos
a nuestras bases. Entonces nos ordenaron que
entregáramos todo a los talibanes. Escribiré
más mientras pueda. Recordad. Otro 11S está
en camino. Estoy desolado. Sarfaraz, comando
afgano )
Así es como cayó Afganistán. Atentos.
(LA TRAICIÓN DE DOHA)
Imaginad que sois el presidente de Estados
Unidos y tras 20 años de combate, miles y
miles de bajas y un gasto formidable estais
empantanados en una guerra que sabéis que
nunca podréis ganar.
O mejor dicho, que el coste y el sacrificio
de intentar ganarla es demasiado alto.
("Recuerdo a Afganistán como una pesadilla
beige polvorienta de un lugar lleno de gente
orgullosa y valiente que no nos quería allí".
Laura Jedeed, american journalist)
Imaginad que en ese preciso instante os presentan
un plan: señor presidente tenemos la fórmula
para escapar del avispero. Tenemos un plan
para evitar nuevas bajas, librarnos de la
sangría económica que supone la guerra,
impedir que nuevos grupos terroristas campen
a sus anchas y de paso quizás lograr algún
rédito geo-económico.
Suena bien, ¿verdad?
Pues... ahora imaginad que ese plan consiste
en pactar precisamente con los talibanes e
incluso facilitar su acceso al poder.
Sí, sí, me habéis escuchado bien.
Queridos amigos, amigas, no sabemos si los
acontecimientos se desarrollaron siguiendo
este guión pero eso es en la práctica exactamente
lo que pasó.
(En 2018 el gobierno de Trump le pidió a
Pakistán que liberara al Mullah Abdul Ghani
Baradar, y el secretario de Estado de Estados
Unidos, Mike Pompeo, viajó y se reunió con
él para comenzar las negociaciones. Baradar
es el actual líder político de los talibanes.
El resultado es que en febrero de 2020 se
firmo el Acuerdo de Doha, un acuerdo al que
el gobierno afgano de Ghani se opuso rotundamente,
aunque, por supuesto, no sirvió de nada.
El acuerdo estableció un calendario para
la retirada de las tropas internacionales,
la liberación de miles y miles de presos
talibanes y la reducción de los ataques aéreos
y también de las operaciones militares norteamericanas.
Todo a cambio de que los talibanes no atacaran
a las tropas internacionales, se comprometieran
a no dar cobijo a grupos terroristas y negociaran
con el gobierno afgano una salida política
al conflicto.)
Eso es lo que se conoce, porque buena parte
del acuerdo sigue y seguirá siendo secreto.
Es decir, que los norteamericanos negociaron
la hoja de ruta del futuro de Afganistán
no con el gobierno afgano, que ni siquiera
estuvo en la mesa, sino con los talibanes.
("El acuerdo de Doha compró a los talibanes
un indulto de un año. Pudieron reagruparse,
planificar, fortalecer sus líneas de suministro,
tener libertad de movimiento, sin temor a
los bombardeos estadounidenses". Andrew Watkins,
member of U.S. Institute of Peace)
Y en cierto modo tiene sentido: Pensadlo bien,
más allá de la cuestión moral que plantea,
si pactas con los talibanes y te aseguras
de que no den cobijo a grupos terroristas
que puedan atacar miel sobre hojuelas:
no tendrás más bajas;
podrás largarte del país sin que Al-qaeda
o cualquier otro grupo campe a sus anchas;
podrás concentrar tu atención y tus recursos
en tu auténtica prioridad: el pacífico y
la contención de China.
Y si encima llegan al poder, entonces, bueno
entonces, además incluso se puede abrir la
puerta a ciertas oportunidades.
Me explico. Afganistán es un país muy rico
en los minerales más codiciados por la industria
tecnológica: minerales como el cobre, el
litio, el cobalto, el niobio, las tierras
raras, y también oro y uranio. De hecho,
según un informe del propio Pentágono del
que se hizo eco el New York Times en 2010,
Afganistán tiene el potencial de convertirse
en la Arabia Saudita del Litio.
(Además, existen proyectos como el gasoducto
TAPI, un proyecto de gasoducto que a través
de 1.814 km podría llevar gas natural desde
Turkmenistán a Pakistán, India y China.
Un proyecto que es propiedad de la petrolera
norteamericana Chevron y que podría aliviar
la dependencia que China tiene del gas natural
ruso al tiempo que reduciría la importancia
estratégica de Irán.
Pues bien, en febrero de 2021 en una visita
según parece coordinada por los propios Estados
Unidos, los talibanes visitaron Turkmenistán
y se comprometieron a proteger este proyecto.
Porque el gasoducto, amigos, tiene que pasar
por Afganistán.)
Y es que el problema que había hasta ahora
es que para explotar los minerales o construir
redes energéticas se necesita estabilidad
política. Mientras estés en pie de guerra
con los talibanes no se puede hacer nada.
Pero el acuerdo de Doha suponía toda una
oportunidad para marcharse de una vez por
todas. Una operación al mejor estilo CIA
Y eso, eso es lo que para muchos analistas
explica que Estados Unidos dejará prácticamente
de atacar a los talibanes a pesar de que estos
recrudecieron sus operaciones contra el ejército
y las instituciones afganas hasta el punto
de que la ONU calificó el 2020 como el año
más violento en el país desde que tiene
registros.
Claro que, un momento, los acuerdos de Doha
pueden explicar el escenario general, pero
no basta para entender completamente porque
demonios el ejército afgano se diluyó tan
rápido. Algo que incluso pilló completamente
desprevenido al propio gobierno de Estados
Unidos.
[Aunque, lo cierto es que la reducción casi
total de los ataques aéreos, el retiro de
los contratistas de las fuerzas aéreas y
la consiguiente desmoralización de las tropas
jugaron un papel clave.]
Atentos.
(EL SAQUEO POR NORMA)
No es la primera vez que se produce una desbandada
en el ejército afgano made in USA.
En otoño del 2015, en la provincia de Kunduz,
una ofensiva de 500 talibanes derrotó a 3.000
soldados y policías afganos y capturaron
una capital provincial por primera vez. Luego
en la provincia de Helmand, unos 1.800 talibanes
vencieron a casi 4.500 soldados y policías.
(“¡Corrieron! ¡Tenían todo lo que necesitaban:
efectivos, armas, municiones, y se dieron
por vencidos!” Omar Jan, Comandante del
Ejército de Afganistán)
Ojo, un apunte importante, no nos equivoquemos.
Esto no quiere decir que el ejército afgano
no haya asumido esfuerzos. Durante estos años
los afganos se han llevado la peor parte.
Tan solo el ejército y la policía han acumulado
en torno a 70.000 bajas.
El caso es que tanto la desmotivación como
la escasez de materiales estaban a la orden
del día.
Pero… ¿Cómo puede un ejército en el que
se ha invertido tanto dinero, más de 80.000
millones de dólares en prácticamente 15
años, tener tantos problemas?
Pues… Una razón está en el tipo de ejército
que los Estados Unidos han diseñado. Un ejército
montado a su imagen y semejanza desplegado
por todo el país mediante una remota red
de puestos avanzados y bases. Una red completamente
dependiente de un complejo sistema logístico
y de apoyo compuesto por aviones y helicópteros
que los afganos eran simplemente incapaces
de gestionar.
(“Cuando la provincia de Kunduz cayó en
manos de los talibanes, muchos soldados murieron.
Estábamos rodeados.No había apoyo aéreo.
En los últimos minutos, nuestro comandante
nos dijo que no podían hacer nada por nosotros
y que era mejor huir. Todos abandonaron la
guerra y escaparon". Abdul Qudus, soldado
afgano de 29 años)
Pero sobre todo tiene que ver con la que quizás
es la característica afgana más destacada
de las últimas décadas: la corrupción masiva.
Y es que veréis, a pesar de las enormes cantidades
de dinero gastadas por los norteamericanos
los soldados afganos tenían sueldos irrisorios,
se podían pasar meses sin cobrar y hasta
la munición escaseaba.
Así que cuándo los talibanes aparecían,
se marcaban todo un Pablo Escobar: “o plata
o plomo”. O se rendían y recibían suministros
e incluso citas y algo de dinero o les matarían
a todos. De hecho, se cree que los talibanes
fueron cerrando acuerdos con oficiales militares
desde hace ya muchos meses.
("Ninguna región cayó como resultado de
la guerra, sino como resultado de la guerra
psicológica",Abbas Tawakoli, comandante del
217o cuerpo del Ejército Afgano)
("Todo el mundo simplemente entregó sus armas
y huyó. No recibimos ninguna ayuda del gobierno
central, por lo que el distrito cayó sin
ningún combate". Rahimullah, un soldado afgano
de 25 años)
El caso es que todo escaseaba porque probablemente
buena parte del dinero gastado por los norteamericanos
esté en lugares como Dubai o Qatar. Por ejemplo,
Ahmed Zia Massoud, un ex vicepresidente afgano
fue acusado de llevarse más de 50 millones
de dólares a Dubai, dónde vivía en una
lujosa mansión y se paseaba en Rolls Royce.
¿Otro ejemplo? Pues, fijaos:
(Los altos mandos del ejército y del gobierno
mentían con las cifras de soldados y se quedaban
con el dinero de muchas nóminas fantasma.
Un buen día los norteamericanos que pagaban
más de 300.000 nóminas se dieron cuenta
de que el número real apenas superaba si
acaso los 250.0000.
Y de las nóminas que sí existían habitualmente
muchos altos mandos y señores de la guerra
se quedaban una buena parte, haciendo que
los soldados cobraran cantidades aún más
miserables. Al final tuvieron que establecer
un sistema de pago electrónico, y aún así
los problemas persistieron.)
Pero no solo era cuestión de la cúpula,
para nada. La corrupción estaba generalizada.
Al fin y al cabo si a un soldado que apenas
cobra unos 200 dólares mensuales, cuando
los cobraba, le das un equipo valorado en
miles de dólares el resultado… No puedo
extrañarnos: el mercado negro.
Eso es exactamente lo que pasó cuándo el
Pentágono trató de equipar al ejército
afgano con gafas de visión nocturna. Desaparecían
constantemente. Y lo mismo ocurría con componentes
de los vehículos, con las armas, la munición,
el combustible y con muchos suministros.
Total, los norteamericanos pagaban las facturas
y el control brillaba por su ausencia.
Además, Los soldados y policías en muchos
casos se dedicaban a cobrar sobornos en los
puestos de control, haciendo que buena parte
de la sociedad se fiera muy poco de ellos
por ser suaves. La policía llegó a convertirse
en la institución más odiada del país.
Porque los talibanes hacían lo mismo: pero
una sola vez, no como la policía que exigía
pagos constantemente.
("El principio talibán es: una vez que pagues
el impuesto (soborno), te dan un recibo que
funciona en todo el país y no se te pedirá
que vuelvas a pagar el impuesto (soborno).
Los agentes de policía, por otro lado, no
emiten recibos por los sobornos que extorsionan.
Ahmad Sayid Azimyan, jefe adjunto de la cámara
de comercio de la provincia de Herat)
Así que si tienes un ejército en gran medida
mal entrenado, mal equipado, con carencias
de todo tipo y encima sin motivación, el
resultado es exactamente el que hemos visto:
cuándo llegaban los talibanes y les amenazaban
muchas fuerzas huían o se cambiaban de bando,
entregandole además a los talibanes sus equipos
militares made in USA.
Un fenómeno que se recrudeció cuando dejaron
de tener el apoyo de los norteamericanos.
Sino luchaban por una causa y a su alrededor
todo era corrupto, ¿Por qué jugarse el tipo?
Este factor, amigos, diezmó las fuerzas afganas
hasta niveles que en realidad estaban muy
por debajo de los 167.000 soldados que supuestamente
tenía el ejército. Algunas fuentes apuntan
a que a la hora de la verdad apenas había
50.000 soldados mal equipados, repartidos
por todo el país sin ninguna estrategia,
dispuestos a luchar.
El resultado, todos lo conocemos.
Pero aún existen otras 2 hipótesis, 2 claves,
que no podemos dejar pasar. Atentos.
(ERRORES FATALES Y PAKISTÁN)
Amigos, amigas, Estados Unidos ha cometido
muchos errores en Afganistán. El más importante
de todos ha sido quizás haber sido incapaz
de crear un ejército y unas fuerzas de seguridad
capaces de vencer a los talibanes.
Y aquí muchos analistas apuntan a una cuestión
muy concreta: el tiempo que se tardó en montar
un ejército afgano.
Porque montar un ejército y una policía
desde cero no es nada sencillo, hacerlo en
Afganistán y encima sufriendo una rotación
enorme por las bajas sufridas lo complica
todo mucho más.
("No tenemos que enseñar a los soldados estadounidenses
a obedecer la ley, a no aceptar sobornos,
a respetar los derechos humanos; vienen al
ejercito habiendo ya internalizado esas cosas".
Tratamos de crear militares a nuestra imagen,
y eso a menudo no es congruente con las circunstancias
políticas y sociales en las que operan esas
fuerzas. Michael Nagata, ex comandante de
EE. UU.)
El caso es que cuándo Estados Unidos invadió
el país y derrotó a los talibanes, durante
unos años hubo una cierta calma. Pero obsesionados
con Irak y con reducir el gasto comprometido,
el Presidente Bush y su secretario de defensa
Donald Runsfell cometieron lo que a la postre
se ha visto como dos grandes errores.
Primero, rechazaron el ofrecimiento de muchos
líderes talibanes de negociar una salida
política. Y segundo se empecinaron en que
Afganistán tuviera unas fuerzas de seguridad
ridículas: apenas 50.000 hombres para controlar
un país enorme. Además el pentágono quería
reducir los costes por lo que se empeñaron
en mantener bajos los salarios y cualquier
gasto derivado de la manutención de la tropa.
Cuando se marchó Rumsfeld en 2006 y los talibanes
intensificaban sus ofensivas apenas se habían
entrenado y equipado a 26.000 soldados afganos.
La decisión resultó ser carísima porque
las carencias del ejército afgano tuvieron
que ser cubiertas durante todos estos años
por tropas norteamericanas, cuyo coste de
despliegue superaba el millón de dólares
por unidad y año.
Lo peor con todo es que el ejército afgano
nunca llegó a consolidarse.Y pensad que un
ejército moderno es mucho más que un soldado
portando un arma. Por ejemplo, se requieren
mecánicos de todo tipo, profesionales de
intendencia o sanitarios. Y nada de eso había
en Afganistán.
Por así decirlo, las decisiones de Bush y
Rumsfield supusieron desperdiciar los mejores
años al tiempo que alimentaron la corrupción
que antes hemos visto.
Y por último amigos, está la hipótesis
de Pakistán.
(Muchos afganos y analistas consideran que
el ejército de Pakistán ha entrenado, equipado,
facilitado medios logísticos e incluso cedido
oficiales, consultores y tropas a los talibanes.
Es decir, que el ejército afgano en realidad
ha hecho frente a una fuerza adiestrada en
buena medida por un ejército mucho más grande
y profesional.
Pero, ¿por qué Pakistán apoyaría a los
talibanes? Pues fundamentalmente para controlar
Afganistán y evitar la influencia india.
Además, está también el tema del gasoducto
TAPI que podría suministrarle gas al país.)
Amigos, amigas, estas son 4 claves que tenemos
que tener en cuenta para entender la caída
tan rápida de Afganistán.
Con todo, las imágenes que hemos visto suponen
una mancha enorme en la gestión de la Administración
Biden. El caos, los nervios, la descoordinación,
un desastre.
Incluso los talibanes han tenido a su alcance
convertir a 2.500 soldados norteamericanos
en rehenes. Les hubiera bastado con atacar
la pista e impedir el despegue y aterrizaje
de aviones.
Si no lo han hecho es porque quizás anhelen
más el gobierno que la guerra. Ahora bien,
¿Qué podemos esperar de los talibanes? ¿A
qué futuro se enfrenta Afganistán?¿Podrá
la resistencia hacerle la vida imposible a
los talibanes? Eso, queridos amigos, amigas,
lo veremos en 2 próximos vídeos aquí en
visualpolitik.
Así que no olvides suscribirte. Y ahora si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.